hey guys it's Jonah here it's the
holiday season that also means the
season of soup has begun I love soup I'm
really excited to be sharing with you my
favorite soup recipes when you drink a
really good bowl of soup you will feel
good and you know that you're being
healthy as well so if you're looking to
lose weight or keep the weight off have
a bowl of soup prior to your meals it
has been proven to control hunger
resulting in you eating about 20% less
for your main meals if you don't like
your vegetables soup is also a great way
to add more vegetables into your diet I
used to date a guy who wouldn't touch
any vegetables it's impossible and I
found out that the only way he would
have his vegetables is if I were to
blend them and turn them into soup
totally work he would happily eat it the
entire serving and didn't even think of
them as vegetables so if your partner or
kids do not like their vegetables try
this trick here are three of my favorite
holiday season soup recipes there are so
delicious filling low in calories easy
to prep and made only with wholesome
ingredients it's the season of winter
squash right now so let's start by
making this rich bowl of coconut curry
pumpkin soup what you'll need are 1 kilo
of pumpkin roasted peeled and cubed 1
medium yellow onion diced 3 garlic
cloves minced 1 tablespoon of fresh
ginger minced half a cup of light
coconut milk 3 cups of vegetable stock 1
tablespoon of olive oil 1 teaspoon of
curry powder 1/2 a teaspoon of cumin 1/2
a teaspoon of turmeric 1 tsp of
coriander seed 1 tablespoon of fresh
lemon juice and salt and pepper to taste
in a large pot heat olive oil over
medium-high heat stir in the garlic
ginger and onion for one to two minutes
until slightly brown and fragrant add in
all the spices continue to stir for
another one minute until spices become
toasted and fragrant then add in the
pumpkin
vegetable stock and coconut milk bring
to a boil cover and simmer for another
10 minutes until pumpkin is tender turn
off the heat and puree all the
ingredients with a hand blender until
smooth seasoned with lemon salt and
pepper serve hot
I've garnished my coconut curry pumpkin
soup with pumpkin seeds and fresh
parsley the richness from the coconut
milk and the slight hint of spiciness
from the curry powder makes it a soul
warming dish winter squashes are also a
great way to thicken your soup without
adding that many calories so this one
large serving only has 130 calories be
sure to include this recipe for
Christmas on new year
the next recipe is the queen of comfort
food creamy mushroom soup the deep
earthy flavor is so soothing and hearty
the classic mushroom soup recipe it
tends to call for a lot of heavy cream
and can be packed with hidden calories
for my recipe we are going to give it a
slight twist and cook it without any
cream yet still maintaining its classic
flavor what you'll need are 500 gram of
fresh wild mushroom thinly sliced 3 cups
of cauliflower costly chopped 1 large
yellow onion diced 1 tbsp of olive oil 3
garlic cloves minced 4 cups of vegetable
stock 1 tablespoon of fresh lemon juice
and salt and pepper to taste
in a large pot add 2 cups of vegetable
stock and cauliflower bring to a boil
cover and simmer for about 10 minutes
and the cauliflower is very tender puree
with a hand blender until smooth and set
aside in a pan heats olive oil over
medium-high heat stir in the garlic
onion and mushroom saute for 5 to 10
minutes until onion and garlic are
golden brown and fragrant and mushrooms
are cooked through
then add 3/4 of the mushroom mixture and
the remaining 2 cups of vegetable stock
into the pureed cauliflower mixture
bring to a boil cover and simmer for 5
minutes until slightly thickened turn
off the heat
and puree all the ingredients with a
hand blender until smooth stir in the
remaining mushroom mixture and seasoned
with lemon salt and pepper serve hot so
the secret creamy ingredient is to add
pureed cauliflower into the mix is an
extremely good source of fiber which
means keeping you fuller for much longer
and it is also very low in calories with
only 72 calories per serving you don't
need a reason to enjoy a hearty bowl of
mushroom soup I like to have it
throughout the year so give this how
they recipe a try
and my final bowl of soup is filled with
sweet potato chunks black beans and
seasoned with lots of intense spices the
ingredients you'll need are 1 and a half
cup of sweet potato peeled and diced
into cubes one can offer black beans
rinsed and drained 1 medium yellow onion
diced 2 garlic cloves minced 1 TSP of
olive oil 1 TSP of cumin 1 teaspoon of
smoked paprika 1 tsp of coriander seed 2
cups of vegetable stock and salt and
pepper to taste
in a large pot heat olive oil over
medium-high heat add garlic and onion
and stir-fry very quickly
just until slightly brown and fragrant
then mix in the sweet potato black beans
and all the spices and continue to
stir-fry very quickly for another minute
then add the vegetable stock bring to a
boil cover and simmer for 15 to 20
minutes until SU potatoes are tender and
cooked through then turn off the heat
scoop out about one cup of sweet potato
and black beans mixture and set aside
puree the rest of the ingredients with a
hand blender until smooth
then turn the heat back on to low and
add back in the reserved 3 potatoes and
black beans season with salt and pepper
and cook very quickly for about 5
minutes just to heat the soup up this
bowl of soup is bursting with flavors
it's high in fiber and protein which
makes it a very satisfying meal we
member good food doesn't mean
complicated ingredients keep it simple
and wholesome to bring out the flavors
of each ingredient so to avoid over
indulging this holiday season and to
keep the weight off include soups into
your meals you can serve them as a
starter for your lunch or dinner or have
them as your afternoon snack soups are
so easy and convenient to make in large
batches which also makes it a really
good food for parties make them and let
me know which is your favorite so
warming soup in the comments below and
be sure to have a beautiful holiday
season we can loved once all the best
you
you